bonjour tirs opérés ali mercier d'être
avec ton direction interférences
l'italie rouvre donc aujourd'hui ses
frontières mais la belgique rouvrira les
siennes le 15 juin le portugal 8
l'espagne début juillet même s'il ya des
exceptions pour les canaries les
baléares la grèce le 1er juillet comment
les italiens interprètent cette
ouverture précoce par rapport à leurs
voisins européens
bon timing pour l'italie où les autres
sont en retard alors tout d'abord
bonjour
il faut dire que tous les italiens qui a
peint une ouverture précoce
tout simplement il faut se rappeler que
honey tallinn
nous avons commencé le look d'un ou à
partir du 4 mars donc par rapport à la
france par rapport à la belgique et par
rapport aussi à d autres pays de l'union
européenne nous sommes en avance sur la
face de toi parce que je vais vous
rappeler dès aujourd'hui en italie l ai
commencé la phase iii d une dizaine de
jours alors j'ai entendu en fait les
berceaux qui ont été personne qui sont
passés à l'intérieur à tout à l'heure
celle qui a boca d'aller de bi milano
paris italie france
je vais vous faire une petite
présentation par rapport à ce qu'ils ont
dit les gens qui ont passé l'intérieur
c'est juste pour définir bien la loi
actuelle au l'italie et en france alors
à partir d'aujourd'hui
owni tél nous sommes officiellement dans
la phase 3 qu'est ce que ça veut dire
qu'elle et concitoyennes des l'union
européenne
il peut circuler si les convictions donc
ça veut dire sans condition tous les
concitoyens qui appartient à la vieille
schengen y compris les concitoyennes de
la grande bretagne à partir du moment
que nous sommes entrés dans la phase de
toi nous n'avons plus l'obligation des
quarantaines donc ça veut dire qu'ils
m'ont concitoyennes français m'ont
concitoyennes belge au mont
concitoyennes
en mai il peut venir en italie les
frontières elles sont ouverts et ils ne
seraient pas obligés de passer par la
garantie
alors allons-y maintenant un moment à
comparer la phase deux doigts d'un point
de vue des interprétations et tisse avec
les interviews j'ai lu que certains
concitoyennes pendant la nuit ils ont
dit oui au l'italie nous pouvons aller
mais le problème c'est le retrouve
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça en france
pour l'instant si nous prenons toujours
les sources du doigt bien entendu
en france pour l'instant c'est à dire à
partir du 11 mai nous pouvons aller en
france
mais attention il n'y a pas une
obligation des 40 m mais il ya une
obligation dé vouloir justifier la
rentrée d'un lobby en fait dans un
entendu j'ai entendu un concitoyen qui
disait il faut auto certifié il faut
justifier et bien sûr parce qu'en france
nous sommes encore dans la phase 2 oui
la france n'a pas n'a pas encore ouvert
ses frontières mais justement est ce
qu'il y a on voit donc une divergence
ans au niveau européen par rapport par
rapport à cela
comment les italiens interprètent ça à
bâle il y a une tête prédation du peuple
mais aussi une interprétation
législatives ont sévi concerne la
l'interprétation du peuple elle est tout
à fait semble les six terrien estime que
par rapport au procès d'avancement donc
ça veut dire dans la phase ii à la face
de toi
aujourd'hui nous pouvons effectivement
ouvrir les frontières parce que nous
avons quand même 10 jouent dansent sous
la progression du virus qu'ovide 19
je vais vous rappeler qu est aujourd'hui
plus ou moins le taux de mortalité loto
de décès et il s'est est de plus ou
moins une soixantaine de personnes mais
ça c'est la mentalité du concitoyennes
mais quel est le problème en europe le
problème en europe que nous avons
permettez moi une liberté à la
circulation
keane libertés fondamentaux sur liberty
constitutionnel nous allons pas contre
le 6 une autre principes fondamentaux
qui est le libère claqué le droit à la
santé
donc aujourd'hui il est en conflit entre
le tout loin des libertés tels que
principes fondamentaux et le droit à la
santé
mais si nous allons prendre la
constitution française et je connais
bien tranquillement son n'a plus
beaucoup de temps c'est bientôt la fin
du journal
donc le problème c'est que nous n'avons
pas une constitution européenne
c'est à dire nous pouvons gérer la
liberté à la santé la liberty à la
situation et chinois et le doigt la
santé en italie comme en france mais
nous ne pouvons pas le gêner au niveau
union de l'aubaine
parce que malheureusement il y attend en
principe constitutionnel est une aubaine
qui peut gérer le trap comment dire le
passage transfrontalier merci beaucoup
tirent opéra n'est d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat au barreau de milan